哈喽哈喽，各位听众朋友们，大家好，我是老潘。欢迎回到PhotoRaising新一期的节目。
这是一档饭摄影谈话类节目。我们希望摆脱故作高深的艺术术语，不做求真求智的教科书，只想和大家聊聊有关摄影的一切。
今天将由我和白熊还有赛文来和大家一起聊天，先请打个招呼。
哈喽大家好，我是白熊。
哈喽大家好，我是赛文。
对，那今天的主题其实挺有意思的，来自于我们自己的群里的一次聊天。
这个主题的名字叫做从废篇聊起，回望来实录看看我们自己在摄影中的进步从何而来。
也说在前边，这里说的废篇也好，或者进步也好，都是指我们自己个人的一些经历和故事。
我们这期节目并不为了去和谁进行比较。
我们是跟自己比较。
对对对，跟自己比较。
只想和大家分享一下我们自己的一些经历和历程。
那么先请一下白熊来跟大家说一说，为什么我们会聊这个话题。
之所以要聊这期节目呢，是因为有一次我在整理我的网盘，我要找一些交片，
然后我就翻到了18192021，差不多这几年的照片，我就随便点开了一个文件家，
然后浏览了一下，哇，太丑了，把我丑哭了。
我就把这几张照片丢到群里，我说你看，这我以前拍的照片拉不拉。
然后赛文老潘他们都分享了一些他们以前拍的照片，
但是他们有一个点字，你看这个是我当时第一次拍交卷就很烂，
我觉得第一次嘛，前有可缘，大家第一第二卷可能都还比较深淑，
不太会构图或者有一些技术上的失误等等，
但我当时已经拍了四五年了，然后我看那些文件家还是就不用经过精挑戏选，
随便点开一张，就是一些我觉得非常没有，怎么说没有意义的一些照片。
但是我后来给，虽然给你们看的是我的第一卷，第二卷交卷，
但是在拍交卷之前，我已经拍了好多年的数码了，所以其实差不多。
对，我选的照片其实也是已经拍过几年照片，
然后但是还持续的在拍那样的照片。
对，然后白熊发了这个东西之后呢，我们两个就秒根，
然后我们的另外一位主播，Robin啊，就藏藏耶耶，一张废片都不肯拿出来给大家看。
我们在这里去去看一下。
然后佳琳呢，是因为她刚刚才开始拍照，
或者说她才刚刚进入到去学习摄影的这样的一个阶段，
现在就讨论她的废片可能稍微有点早，
所以今天这些节目呢，就我们三个来跟大家聊这个话题。
那我们既然说到废片，我们就从废片开始吧。
那白熊可以先说一说你到底找到了哪几张怎么样的废片，
然后为什么你觉得她是废片？
因为我大概是从一二年左右，一二一三年左右开始拍照的。
所以其实离我刚才说的18192021，
其实中间已经拍了小四五年了。
然后我又仔细回想了一下，因为当时正好我有一个朋友，
他家里有一些过期的胶卷，大概三十来卷吧，
都是过期的，有过期两三年的，也有过期十年的。
因为工作比较忙，他说不拍了，他看我在拍胶卷都寄给我了。
然后我一下子拿到这些胶卷之后就觉得特别开心，
就有一种好像你按快门就免费了，
然后我只要再选一个很便宜的冲扫就二三十块钱那种嘛，
就你相当于按一下快门也就一块钱或者一块钱都不到这种价格，
就好像有了一种免费拍胶卷的这种错觉。
所以我在那几年真的拍了很多很多卷，
拍之前也不思考，我看很多照片就是要么就是没对上胶，
没对上胶就是因为那些胶片机比较老，
它的对焦速度没那么快，我可能刚抬手按下去，
它还没反应过来我就按了，这种情况有很多。
然后还有就是当时随心飞去各个地方玩，
然后也是看到这边好看拍一张那个好看拍一张，
首先它的构图就很奇怪，会有很多无意义的一些路人电线干被拍进去，
然后以及那些胶卷已经过期了嘛，造点有特别厉害，
颜色也就整个画面偏轻，因为就是二三十块钱的扫描嘛，
校色上就是那些冲扫店也不会帮你弄得特别认真，
所以回看那些画面不管是颜色也好，构图也好，
当时肯定是拍得很开心的，当时的开心仅限于按快门的那个过程是开心的，
结果我已经不去考虑了，
所以现在那些照片对我来说不能说不完美，就是无效，
我觉得就是可以用无效画面，
就是照片没有意义对吧？
对，无效画面来形容，
而且是一个画面和我想表达的一些内容是严重不符合的，
你看你找到的这些照片其实也是数码转换胶片的过程，
就是我们今天再回看这些费片的时候，
其实我们三个是一样的，
我们都选择了数码转胶片，
走这个过程中拍出来的这些照片，挺神奇的一个事情。
嗯，但是赛文他选的那些还是比较他早期的那些数码照片，
对，我选的都是一些数码照片，我最开始是数码齐家的。
哦，这样子，数码齐家。
对，进入赛文讲他的费片之前，
我想先回到刚才白泳讲的一个问题，
就是有很多的朋友在刚刚入门拍照片的时候，
都会有一种习惯我尽可能去买一些便宜的胶卷，
或者是甚至过期的胶卷，
因为它看起来会节省成本，
同时的话我选择一些比较便宜的冲扫，
来去在一开始用来摸索自己的技术熟悉机器，
但是我其实有一个观点，
就是我觉得如果你是真的想要去学习拍胶片的朋友，
特别是你希望能够去获得胶片能够给你带来的真正的快乐，
或者是理解胶片的意义的，
我其实会建议大家上来就用比较好的卷，
然后用比较好的冲扫，
因为你能真正看到胶片拍出来是什么样子，
而不用浪费这个钱，
虽然你听起来好像按一次画面一张是这个一块钱左右，
但是实际上你会花掉很多的时间和精力去拍这些东西。
对，因为我后来换了录来，
然后无意之中用了一次好的冲扫之后，
我才得到了真正的拍胶片的快乐，
当然这个我们就之后再讲。
好的，那白胸对肺片的定义其实就是无效的照片，
就对你来说这个画面没有意义，
没有达到你的预期，
和没有达到你想表达的东西，对吧？
那老潘，你的肺片？
我的肺片其实就像刚刚说的一样，
我选出来的这些肺片是我最早最早的几卷胶片，
我跟白胸不太一样的地方是我是从中华服务入门的，
所以我以上来的第一台胶片机就是路莱3.5F，
然后我那会还很认真的去买了，应该是泡塔的卷，
如果没有记错的话，就去拍了。
拍了前两卷之后，
我当时的感觉就是我不知道自己在按什么。
当时我其实很喜欢这照片，我还发了朋友圈，
你想想看，那时候会发朋友圈，
就是你觉得这照片还不错，
所以你才会发朋友圈。
今天回去看的时候呢，
我觉得有几点，
第一个就是，
那个时候有一个误区，
就觉得胶片拍出来的东西就是好看的，
或者胶片拍出来的东西就是好的，
但实际上你在仔细回去看的时候，
它会有曝光不足的问题，
它会有构图的不足的问题，
有很多画面中的细节，
你根本就没有关注到，
以及那会我特别喜欢拍一种照片，
我不知道这个大家有没有跟我一样的朋友，
我站在路中间，一条路通向远方，
然后两边有两排建筑。
现在也会拍，
只是不发了而已。
我现在不太会拍这种照片了，
那那个时候我觉得这样的照片好棒呀，
包括我去什么黄山玩，
然后去西安玩，
我的教卷里面有一半都是这样的内容，
然后还有一些呢，
就是完全是在技术上的失误，
所以我觉得今天在回看那些照片的时候，
甚至于都到不了讨论画面内容的这样子的一个，
他之所以对我来说是费片，
就是因为第一个他技术上完全是不成立的，
第二个他完全是无意识的拍摄，
我再回去想一想，
我是想不出来为什么我站在那个场景下，
那个时候我一定要按这张快门的，
所以这就是我的费片和费片的一些定义，
在那个时候，
三文呢？
其实我选的照片和你们选的就不太一样，
因为我是最开始拍数码的嘛，
拍数码就会涉及到一个，
所以大家都会做的事情就是做后期，
然后我这次选的呢，
其实也跟老板一样，
我都是从我的朋友圈选的，
朋友圈的黑历史，
就专门挑的那些，
当时以为好看，
然后现在觉得哇，
我总会拍这种玩意儿的东西出来，
陪我圈现在能够半年可见，
你知道吗？
对对对，
如果我能够半年可见，
我都要去删陪我圈，
没办法去看那些黑历史，
然后我就从我大概是18年19年之前的一些照片，
当时是会拍一些人物，
更偏向于写真的，
现在的我更喜欢拍肖像，
但我觉得那些照片可能更偏于写真，
我当时拍完写真之后，
我做了调色周，
我做了一件就很离谱的事情，
就是去网上，
我记得是当时的淘宝上去下载的那种，
例白是韩文或者日文的那种排版，
它是韩文日文加上英文的小字，
我完全不知道它什么意思，
但我觉得它拍上去特别好看，
我当时就喜欢做这事，
然后这是一种，
然后还有另外一种就是HDR，
就是给一张很普通的照片，
可能就是我记得有一张照片就是，
我在地点上拍了一个人，
这个人他正好在抬头看我身后，
因为我坐在对面，
他看我身后的上面应该是看到哪一站，
就拍了这样一张照片，
然后给他加一个HDR效果做成了黑白，
这感觉就是口大抽身的，
然后这个照片从我先看来看，
首先一个我可能不会觉得他心脏好照片，
因为他一个他没有看我，
我其实是一个抓拍，
或者更年格意上点其实也算是偷拍，
就是跟我们就是我去拍他这个人，
然后他没看我，
但是我就觉得他很好，
然后我给他加了一个HDR效果之后，
感觉就像是拍出了一个人文照片的感觉，
刻板印象吧，我觉得就是，
然后还有一类照片就是饱和度战士，
就是饱和度不拉满那种，
而且有严重的偏色，
特别是我当时在重庆拍了一组建筑，
到那个解放碑，我还端了三脚架，
去那边拍长报拍完之后，
哎呦，挑成一个我觉得夜晚应该要蓝一点，
然后片的整个画面是偏紫色的，
然后饱和度特别高，
你知道那种照片吗？
不懂配色，赛博朋克，
玉石不绝，亮泽血，
现在看来他是非常偏心，
因为其实多数都是形式上的，
就是这些形式在在我这里，
他可能已经是属于过时或者被淘汰了，
或者是说我已经，
不会被这种照片所吸引的这种情况下，
我就会觉得他是个废片，
所以其实我跟白雄是技术问题，
你是审美问题，
对，不过我觉得可能是审美问题，
对,
所以你的废片其实是，
随着你自己的审美提高，
随着时代的发展，
就是过去的那些老的审美，
可能你就不喜欢他了，
对,
我不知道你们还有没有印象，
就是在，
应该是2010年代左右，
还是2000年左右吧，
我们那个时候还很小的时候，
有一种非常流行的照片，
就是黑白照片里面会流出一个颜色，
比如说灯笼的红色保留下来，
雨傘的红色保留下来，
那会觉得哇，
这样的照片好美啊，
现在回去再看这个东西，
我也干过，
对，完全受不了，我也干过，
对,
今天再回去看就觉得哇，
这什么东西啊，
很神奇，
我还记得当时那个画面是，
我去拍一组跑马拉松的人，
快到终点的时候有一对老夫妻，
他们手拉着手一些，
我是在10公里处，
然后他们要准备充现了，
我觉得那个画面挺温馨的，
我就拍下来，
但是我又想让背景，
这些杂气杂巴的颜色给去掉，
所以我就只保留了两个人物的颜色，
后面背景就都黑白化了，
对,
它其实和大光圈是不是一个逻辑，
就是突出这个东西吗？
对,
就感觉只保留一两个颜色，
或者是某一个东西有颜色，
它是一个很突兀的事情，
比大光圈会更突兀一点。
对,
其实有种没必要，
有种化石天足的感觉。
对,
所以随着时代的发展，
我们的审美都会改变，
然后流行也会改变，
那其实我在找刚才说的这些费片之外，
我还有想过我最早最早开始拍摄的时候的那些照片，
我跟塞文一样，
我先拍数码，
然后才会拍交片，
所以我那个时候数码照片也会加非常厚重的滤镜，
那种萌龙的，
然后泛着白光的，
就奇奇怪怪的这种颜色，
那会儿都觉得，哇，好美好美，
现在再回头去看的时候，
就觉得人怎么可以会有这样子奇怪的经历，
会手动去加一些漏光，
其实是数码照片，
对,
加点交片漏光的那种红条，
我发现你在骂富士的X-HUB，
对,
他现在给你内置了这个功能，
我觉得那个时候拍照片，
我现在回去看的话，
我会觉得就是再找一种形式，
就其实根本没有真正的去关注照片的内容，
而是说我们选择了一种形式，
为了修而修图，
对,
那时候没有想过说我为什么要拍他，
只是觉得好看，
然后好像有意思，
好像别人怎么拍，
所以我们也这么拍，
嗯,
跟一下风嘛，
对,
这就是我们的来时路，
我感觉很多人是这样，
最开始，
我摆相机是为了拍妹的，
然后没拍成，
然后开机拍风光，
那我不是，
我一上来就是拍风光的，
那我们有第一个阶段，
我觉得我的第一个阶段应该就是扫机，
要么就是拍同学，
当时大学里拍同学，
或者就是拿着相机出去扫机，
然后去了最多的一个地方就是一家，
因为天热的时候就可以在一家里面，
一家现在拍照还好像出片，
很多人一到夏天就会看到一家有这种，
专门去一家打卡拍照的地方，
那些家具区啊什么的，
很多很多，
对,
我还给我那个两个大学同学，
我给他们拍了一组写真，
他做成了一本册子，
在一家吗？
在重庆的一家拍的，
一家养活了一批摄影师，
那我们聊完来时路啊，
聊完这些过去的黑历史，
我也想问一下，
既然我们觉得那个时候的照片是废片，
也就意味着我们现在的审美，
不再是那个样子了，
我们某种程度上，
相比起过去的自己是有了进步的，
所以我很想问一下你们两位，
就是今年到现在为止，
已经过了一半的时间，
在这半年中，
你今年拍的照片中，
你最喜欢的是哪一张？
然后和那个时候，
你刚选出来的这些废片去比，
为什么这张照片你觉得它好？
那我先来，
其实我选的那张照片是我今年5月份，
就4月底到5月初，
我去新疆大概呆了有半个多月，
这张照片其实比较简单，
它就是一个人物的肖像，
就是一个女孩，
然后蹲着，
然后瞇着眼睛，
背景是天空，
它其实是蹲在草原上，
然后就是一张半身的肖像，
然后在拍的时候呢，
是这样的，
因为我们当时是去草原徒步，
到草原徒步的时候，
就走到了一个牧民的家里，
其实牧民他们是跟着季节会转的，
他们所以相对于他们从4月份到6月，
都会呆在这个地方，
就是在这里有个小房子，
然后有一个草场，
里面会养一些羊啊，
有马牛牛之类的，
然后我们去的时候，
正好是五一节期间，
本来是只有两个老人，
然后还有一个女孩的舅舅，
他们俩他和他弟弟是放假，
正好放假，
然后就回到草原这样的玩，
然后我们去了之后，
就到他们家里去玩嘛，
因为其实说是家，
就是很大的一片草场，
然后去那儿拍了一些照片之后，
他说他们舅舅在前面放羊，
他就带我们去，
然后我相信我们是大概五六个人，
然后就跟着他去，
在过程当中，
因为我就发现，
他和他弟弟其实是非常的，
就那种很干净你知道吗，
就那种小孩子，
然后他说他们放假了，
然后就回到草原上来，
就陪他们的外公外婆类随将的，
然后他们就带我们去，
我其实中间就一直在拍他，
但是我拍了一些有一些正面的肖像，
我最终选择这张，
其实我是觉得很有意思的是，
他好像在享受风的感觉，
就是他当时是瞇着眼睛的，
然后他的头发，
就是他前额的一些头发，
正好风吹了，有点飘起来了，
对，然后就感觉特别的美，
然后而且特别的干净，
这就是我特别喜欢的这样照片。
就很美好感觉，
你可以想象到他可能脑海里面正在，
想象的那些美好的生活，
美好的未来，
或者对未来的憧憬什么的，
就是很多美好的词汇，
可以被加到这张画面里面去。
是的，是的，
包括我当时还问了，
他和他弟弟一个问题，
就是说他如果以后想去城市的话，
他们想去哪里？
他说他是想去北京，
然后他弟弟想去杭州，
就你会感觉特别纯，
你就会被那种单纯的那种情绪所感觉，
所以我当时特别喜欢这张照片。
对，那就是这张照片，
其实还有一点就是，
大家到时候在双手子里面可以看到这张照片，
其实天和草坪的分割线正好是在人的脖子位置。
所以经常我们会看到群里面，
也会有朋友提到说，
这个分割线是不是不能切脖子啊什么，
其实没有关系对吧，
大家来看这张照片，
不会觉得有任何突兀的地方，
这张这个分割线往上一点或者往下一点，
我觉得都没有在中间的位置正好，
因为它反而让你的视线能够完全的落在人的脸上，
就特别特别好。
所以你喜欢它的原因是因为，
你觉得这张照片的内容和这个人物的状态就特别好。
对，因为我选废片的时候，
我也选了一些以前拍的写真，
然后你会发现他们有两个，
就是这张照片和那些照片，
它有个很明显的区别就是，
你能感觉到这张照片是自然的，是真实的，
你能感受到这些人他的情绪，
或者他当时的状态，
而你看以前的那些写真内的照片，
它更多像是在摆一个很美的动作，
或者是说可能并不是他真正的状态，
或者是并不适合他，
但它只是在摆着，
只是有一个形式在那里，
但是并没有一个你能够真正吸引你的东西。
所以我觉得这就是变化。
很棒，很棒。
那白熊呢，你会选哪张照片？
你今天也拍了很多照片，我感觉。
我选的这张照片是今年春节的时候，
应该是就是大年初一，
因为大年初一的上海马，
就基本上就是一个空城的状态，
所以路上的车行人都特别少，
然后我就顺着往家的方向走，
然后走到了南北高架和沿路高架的立交桥那边，
目之所及各种高高矮矮的高架，
然后柱子人行道以及地上的斑马线，
散落在画面周围的有信号灯，
有红的、绿的、黄的。
我在人行天桥上来回走了几步，
一直在去看，在去等这个灯的颜色，
看它是什么样的一个颜色的循环。
大概找了十分钟左右，
我就找到了一张照片的一个画面的视角，
画面的左边是一个高架桥的柱子，
然后前面是一个信号灯，
画面的中间也是柱子，
再加远一点的信号灯，
画面的右边也是柱子，
画面的上面是高架桥，
然后下面是地上的斑马线，
就是我找了一个角度把这些颜色非常和谐的位置，
然后拍了下来，
我喜欢这个的是组织的非常的和谐，
就没有觉得哪个东西是突兀的。
史蒂芬肖雄，
然后当时感受就是这个角度，
因为我前后真的走了大概有十分钟，
我去等那个信号灯，
等它的绿色，
后面是黄色，
然后右边是红色，
等这个信号灯也等了一会儿，
让他们正好有一个颜色错开的这个点，
然后去拍了这张。
是的，这个信号灯的位置我觉得非常的点睛，
很神奇，
就是它非常的让这张照片平衡，很舒服。
而且这张照片特别神奇的地方是，
确实就是构图非常细致，
你看远处的那个信号灯，
它没有跟立交桥全部贴合在一起，
它是有点空隙的，
在这个信号灯的边上还能看到上海三千套的影子，
然后前景的这个右转控制，
我其实一般来说不太喜欢画面中有这个文字，
就是你会有母语羞耻，
你看到你认识的文字，
你会想它的意义是什么，
而不是看它的形式。
但是这个我觉得右转控制在这里就特别好，
特别神奇的一张照片，
就结构很美，
很漂亮，
这个是我以前绝对绝对绝对不会拍的一个画面，
对，就是但是这两年，
就是应该是去年今年，
我觉得我的眼睛大概能看到这种画面的元素，
看到之后会去找合适的一个构图，
把它们组合在一起。
对，这个构图每一个元素和其他元素之间互相的关系都非常的巧妙，
包括地上的这个光斑，
它都没有跟别的东西融合在一起，
都是有自己的独立的空间呢。
很神奇，
很奇妙，
很奇妙。
对，所以其实就是在构图，
在这些观察上跟你之前拍的照片很不一样了，
很不一样，
对，我记得你选费片的时候选过一张是有一个船连接在一起的桥，
当时你是站在一个高的地方去拍这个船的，
然后他们就会出现很多的东西会互相穿插在一起，
然后右边多出来的一个像建筑一样东西又挡住了一部分，
就看起来就是随手拍了一张，
这个的话就更像是深思熟虑之后去选择的构图。
对，就是能通过这个画面，
能感受到是去寻找过的或者去等待过的，
不是随意按的。
是,
对,
确实最近白熊拍的照片和之前拍的真的完全不一样。
很不一样，
真的很不一样，
真的很不一样。
待会会说，
为什么？
哪个时间点放，
对,好,
那来老潘，
然后我有点贪心，
其实我选来选去，
其实我最后还是决定想分享两张照片，
这是我今年到现在为止，
我觉得没有办法去区分我更喜欢哪张的两张，
一张呢是我在新年之前，
就是今年的二月份左右，
在俄罗斯的圣比德堡拍摄的一张宽幅照片，
当时我在圣比德堡的街头走了好几个小时，
又坐了这个公交车一系列的这种油档之后，
也没有找到一张好的照片，
就那天就觉得拍照不是特别顺利，
早上拍的所有的照片都觉得不太满意，
走着走着我在一个桥上看到了很多的军人开始，
向一个方向去走，
我就拍了几张照片，
然后我就跟着他们的步伐再往桥的另一边走，
那走到下桥的位置的时候，
我突然看见了另外一批军人从反方向走过来，
我就拍了一张照片，
然后这张照片，
我在后来在放大去看的时候，
我发现一件非常神奇的事情，
就是从右往左走的所有的士兵都是白人，
从左往右走的所有的士兵都是黑人，
我后来了解了一下，
好像是柯麦龙顾庸军，
然后有不少的这样子的军队在为这个额物战争服役等等等等，
然后这个场景我觉得非常非常符合，
宽幅照片的一个状态，
它横着铺满了整个画面，
画面的右边是建筑，
左边有广告牌，
广告牌上还是有关于一些比较美好的类似于活动或者是一些海报，
然后跟在冰天雪地里正在穿行的军人形成了一个很好的对比，
然后画面中还有另外一条路走向远方，
所以它就形成了一个结构非常完整，
是我认为在我在那次拍摄的所有宽幅照片里面最好的一张，
上面还有两个人行道那么一个向左一个向右，
就一个近一点一个远一点，
对也非常的舒服，
对有两个人行道的标识，
一个正好是右往左一个是左往右，
跟他们的人群的走路关系也是互相契合的，
所以那张照片拍完之后又觉得今天就行了，
就今天拿它再没有拍到更好的照片，
今天就直了，
因为我去俄罗斯拍照相当于是每一天的成本还是挺高的嘛，
算下来平均的话酒店吃饭，
就如果这一天没有一张照片的话还是会觉得有点遗憾的，
另外一张的话就是5月初我在伊斯坦波尔的。
跟埃明尔斯曼一起带工作坊的那次，
是一张四成五拍的肖像照片，
是我最后一天拍四成五，
我当时是选择一天拍四五，
一天拍宽幅，一天拍四五一篇宽幅，
然后这是我最后能来得及把照片送去当地的一个冲扫店，
冲扫的时间，
所以那天下午我就沿着海岸线一直往南走，
就是从海边一直往下一直往南，
在某一个小小的平台上我看到了一个人，
他推着一辆摩托车过来，
然后他把摩托车停在了这个平台上，
可能在休息，
然后他穿了一个淡蓝色的肠胃衣，
一个白色的裤子，
我觉得特别特别有意思的一个人物，
所以我就跟他说我说我能不能给你拍张肖像，
他开始的时候有一点疑惑，
因为他不会说英语，
后来我就给他看了我之前拍的一些照片，
然后跟他交流了几句用这个翻译软件，
旁边还有给他的朋友，
他那个朋友是一个英语老师，
很神奇，
然后他后来他才说我是英语老师，
我说那你帮我翻译就完了，
我就不需要这个翻译软件，
他就帮我搁店一个人说，
说我想给他拍照啊，怎么怎么样，
他就过去了，
过去的时候呢，
他就手上拿着自己的头盔，
后来我就跟他说我说你能不能把头盔戴上，
然后他就把头盔戴上了，
然后本来他的头盔是把这个户幕镜打开的，
后来他在我按下快门前，
我在调整这个机器的时候，
他就把户幕镜放下来了，
然后他让他朋友问我要户幕镜打开还是放下来，
我就说放下来，
我就拍了这张照片，
然后第三天，
也就是工作坊的最后一天，
我收到这张照片的时候，
是在教室里，
艾命正在给大家看编排，
我就拿我的电脑在下载这个照片，
然后这张照片在桌面上，
艾命正好走过我背后，
他当时就说，
他说这是谁拍的，
说这张太好了，
就特别神奇，
我自己后来仔细去看的话，
我也觉得这张照片就完美的符合我对于，
用四五去拍摄怎么样的肖像的一个想象，
它是我一直想要找的那种轻微的怪异感，
然后这个人物的姿态非常放松，
是我到目前为止我觉得拍过最好的一张肖像，
所以这两张就是我的选择。
是的,
同样你看其实这个水平线，
它也是切头的，
也在脖子上，
我觉得这原因是一位身高的原因，
对如果我再高一点，
比如说我有个1米9，
虽然我来1米8都没有，
我还想像我有1米9，
1米9我就可能我的镜头会更高一些，
那这个海平面可能就会更往下一些，
我们这个身高它可能真正好，
这个就是我端起相机，
或者是我架着相机的这个海平面的位置。
我觉得这个位置就挺好的，
你可能高一点之后这个人，
他反而就会有点，
可能从上面的角度拍下去又会不一样。
对,
他可能会让人显得就很矮，
就没有那么舒展的姿态了。
所以这两张就是我的选择，
我觉得比起我之前选的那些费片来说，
他们是有内容的，
并且他们符合我使用的这个设备，
我想要拍成什么样的照片，
我觉得这是，
我现在看到他们，
我觉得跟那个时候的那些费片最不一样的地方。
然后这个画面上我喜欢的是，
这个男生他的衣着就是为衣为裤，
就是一个非常普通的一个着装，
但是他又带了个摩托车头盔，
是护目镜是盖下来的，
就有一点这种科幻的感觉。
对，就会有很奇妙的感受。
对，这种反差感很好。
就可以看很久这张照片，
就是你可以仔细去看，
包括他身上，
他衣服上的文字写了什么，
然后他这个，
你可以想象他当时是什么样的一个状态。
对,
因为我最近一直在寻找这种画面中，
轻微的怪异感，
就是我觉得这是我会长期，
希望在我的某一个项目里面去寻找的东西，
所以这张照片我觉得我就找到了一些，
我真正想要的这些元素，
那我也是从这张照片开始，
我和艾密也去讨论了，
说我明年可能会或者今年甚至我可能会再找时间回伊斯坦波尔，
然后沿着波茲普鲁斯海峡，
从黑海到马里马拉海一直去拍，
沿着欧洲再回亚洲这样，
去看海边的这些东西，
所以这张照片对我来说也是一个方向的确定，
就这两张让我觉得有点难以抉择，
也是我目前用的最多和我最想要去创作的两种工具，
这就是我们分享到今年为止，
到期间为止我们最喜欢的照片，
有了这个对比之后，
我们就可以进入下一个话题，
那你们觉得你们的照片是什么时候开始进步的，
由那样子的照片到现在拍的这样的照片，
是有哪些节点或者哪些关键的阶段，
你们发现，
好像我不再拍以前的照片了，
或者那种照片拍的更少了，
现在这种照片拍的更多了，
你们是怎么样找到这个方向？
我觉得这些节点，
它不是一件事情，
它可能真的是很多事情，
我回忆了一下，我还列了一下，
首先从最早我觉得，
有一次进一步应该是1617年那会，
民宿比较火，
当时有很多做民宿的平台，
然后我当时受顾于一个平台去拍一些上海的民宿，
然后在这个尾派中，
我学会了用三脚架，
学会了一些室内拍摄的一些方法，
以及后期怎么样去修图，
然后这是一个节点，
我觉得有了商单之后，
它相当于是一种外部的压力，
逼迫你去进步，
去思考以前完全不会用的东西，
比如说三脚架，
比如说一些横平数值的构图等等，
然后一次进步我印象里是，
我去安娜亚的时候，
我当时想拍一点不一样的，
然后我就找了一些网上人家拍安娜亚比较好的，
我模仿一模一样的去拷贝它的一些视角，
去找那个咖啡店，
去找那个海岸线，
拍了一套，
我突然觉得好像有一点什么东西开窍了，
但我那时候说不清楚，
我觉得那个点是我记得非常牢的，
到时候也可以选一些图放修诺子里面，
然后一个节点是我买了路来之后，
当时也是有一组家庭照，
有父母，小孩，爷爷，奶奶，
然后他们说要冲哈苏，
所以这也是我第一次冲扫哈苏，
也是用的是比较好的卷，
确实效果真的很不一样，
就是跟以前那种，
我之前说的用的这种过期卷，
什么二三十块钱的冲扫，
出来的效果完全不一样，
就我们刚才说的，
对，就是刚才说的，
我突然发现，
原来胶片的这种画质感觉，
颜色的过渡可以是这样的，
我后来有一些重要的拍摄，
都会狠狠心上哈苏的冲扫，
然后我觉得这也是我记下来的一个节点，
然后一个节点是photorism之后，
你要被迫去看很多的画册，
了解很多的摄影师，
其实像我在做播客之前，
很多摄影师我都不认识，
什么Alexos，不认识的，
什么新地形都不认识的，
什么李福利德兰德是谁啊都不认识，
但是做了播客，
你必须得去看这些人的东西，
那久而久之，
他们的作品一遍两遍三遍，
你第一遍看的时候，
第二遍看的时候，
不会有一个很立杆建议，
说给了你一个什么正反馈，
我觉得看画册就是一个，
非常循序见尽的这样的一个过程，
你可能看了一年两年之后，
他可以帮助你打开你的视野，
看到一些你看不到的场景，
就比如说我刚才我描述的这张立交桥，
我觉得多少都跟那些大师的一些照片是有关系的，
我也不是说想去刻意模仿谁，
可能就是一些潜移默化的作用。
对，我觉得潜移默化这个词用的很好，
就是画册它不能够给你带来瞬间的提高，
你不会因为看了某一本画册，
哪怕它卖一万块两万块的画册，
你不会因为看了这本画册，
你就突然之间技术提高了，
但当你看得足够多，
然后看得足够长时间之后，
在未来的某一天，
你站在某一个路口的时候，
你脑海中会突然出现，
你应该这样拍这张照片的这样子的一个影子，
就是我现在就会常常会有这样子的想法。
我还问过包括像Mark啊，
包括像Jerome嘛他们，
他们其实也都非常非常喜欢收藏和看摄影画册，
Mark每一次去哪里，
他都会去找一找有没有好的画册可以带回去。
其实我觉得还有一个很重要的一点就是，
你看的不同摄影师，
哪怕是在比如说拍美国，
有很多人拍美国，
但每个人拍的不一样。
视角不同。
在这种情况下，
对你看了很多之后，
你会在拍一个东西的时候，
你会有很多的选择，
你知道不止只有一种拍法，
你知道你可以去尝试不同的拍摄，
或者说你比如说你看到哪张照片，
你想到某个摄影师，
但你可以在他的基础上再去做一些自己的东西。
我觉得就是看画册一方面也带来的很大的一个作用。
然后还有一点就是，
去年参加了Jerome的工作坊，
在一个非常高压的三天的学习里，
三四天的拍摄里，
走出舒适圈去拍以前不会拍的东西，
看以前不会看的画面，
然后又会有Jerome他会给你一些指导，
给你一些建议，
可能就简单的一两句话，
但是又是因为高压的环境，
希望自己能出作品不要丢脸，
所以会让你去打开你的眼睛吧。
然后最后一个点是，
我觉得去年换了Mamiya之后，
我觉得Mamiya跟路莱又是完全不同的两种中画幅器材，
一个是单反的结构六成六，
一个是庞州的结构六成七。
我在用了之后，
我已经今年已经想把路莱再出掉了，
我觉得路莱不适合我，
因为路莱来的构图基本上大的来说，
可能就是放中间或者偏一点，
你要像六成七的话，
其实可以有拍出更多，更有张力的画面等等。
可能性更多。
我还记得非常清楚，
就是当时我应该是在大理还是在哪个地方，
就是白熊去参加Jerome这个工作坊的时候，
他还专门把他的拍的照片给我看。
他当时，
我记得有一幕是不是你们捷克的时候，
会在大屏上放大家的照片，
对，轮流的。
然后他好像还录了个视频给我看，
我记得非常清楚。
我就当时就说，
我说,
我觉得这照片不是你以前绝对不会拍这些东西，
就这次完全就不一样了。
对，Jerome的韩定量还在提高，
请你去我做个广告，
就是今年的11月份，
我们也会跟Jerome Cicini在继续合作，
在墨西哥城去做一个工作坊，
详细的信息，
大家可以在我们的收納子里边，
也可以去我们的公众号里面去寻找。
Jerome呢,。
就是像刚才白熊说的一样，
是一个很高压的老师，
请来的朋友们做好心理准备。
所以这样回看总结一下，
一个就是器材的升级，
一个就是画册多看，
然后一个就是有老师的教导，
我觉得就是多方面的原因吧。
棒，那赛文呢？
我其实最开始学习摄影的时候，
是我刚开始工作，
然后我自己去分期买了一台加能，
那那个时候是其实非常的表面，
那个时候单纯的就是想拍人，拍电，
也就是拍妹啊，
其实后面的几年，
基本上就属于一直在这个讯话里面拍妹拍妹，
然后或者是拍一些扫接照片，
但是都是非常的表面，
可能都会去学一些网上的构图，
然后比如说经典的什么，
三分法呀，
这么二分法，
或者是对称构图，
黄金风歌，
黄金螺旋，
是的,
他就会学这种东西，
但其实那个时候更多是一些形式上的，
就像我之前那些照片一样，
他就是一些形式上的，
真正的发生改变是2021年的时候，
那个时候跟白熊有点类似，
接了一个上海的非拍社群，
我每周大概要多的时候，
每周要拍七天或者拍六天，
我当然都是下班的时候去拍，
每天拍两个小时，
拍了一段时间之后，
我就拍两三个月，
就你会发现一个很大的问题就是，
我一直在拍这样的照片，
我就想我要拍得不一样，
所以我即便在拍同样的场地，
可能说人也不会差别很大，
或者流程结婚一样的情况下，
我会再开始思考我要拍的怎么不一样，
我要拍的跟过去不一样，
跟我上次拍的不一样，
所以我在开始尝试用不同的焦段，
我用广角去拍更近的画面，
或者我用长焦也去拍一些更特写的东西，
就是会去思考这些东西，
你最开始帮别人拍，
然后你慢慢的就开拓展到自己身上，
你自己有点休息时间周末的时候，
你也想去拍自己的东西，
你也想拍自己喜欢的东西，
所以那个时候我觉得一部分就是你量变产生的质面，
就是我那个时候高强度的，
就是一直在拍拍了大概半年多，
所以那个时间我在拍摄上发生了很大的变化，
我对各个镜头的焦段该怎么用适合拍什么的场景，
或者是一些构图上如何去寻找一些不一样的点，
然后就会有一些变化，
但是那个时候可能更多是在于结构，
或者画面的组织上面的，
但其实还没有到内容级部分，
然后第二个节点是在之后大概是22年23年，
我那个时候很大一个有意思点，
就是我开始想要去了解跟摄影相关的东西，
所以我当然去看艺术室和摄影室，
所以我当然就去研究摄影室，
当然第一张照片拍清招的是谁，
然后去看这些东西，
这个它很有意思点，
就是你了解了艺术室的发展脉络和摄影室的发展脉络，
你知道人们的审美或者说整个艺术的发展是怎么样的，
那个时候你就开始去思考自己的照片了，
就思考的更多是说你的内容是什么，
然后是比如说你要拍什么东西，
所以那个时候就会刻意的去训练自己的观察，
就是你会去看到一些自己以前看不到的东西，
更细微的点，
但那个时候接触更多的还是片日式摄影，
就是日本的摄影，
就是他们可能会拍一些日常的微小的很细微的东西，
然后在大概就是去年，
就去年我来PR就来杭州之后，
我其实是接触了很多，
就是通过拍老师这边，
别这么客气，
就接触了很多那种欧美的一些摄影师拍的东西，
你就慢慢的形成了对自己照片的一种想法，
然后你可能关注的就不再只是说照片的形式，
或者是你一个一个闪光的点，
而更多的发展到说你真正关注的话题是什么，
你真正想拍的内容是什么，
所以我觉得对我来说就是这样一个发展的脉络，
而且前期和现在很大的一个区别就是，
它就是一些基本东西，技术啊构图东西，
它反而就变成那种很根本的，
就是你到一个地方，
你大概知道你自己会想怎么拍。
对，你不需要去想怎么构图这件事情。
对，对，不用去想这东西的，
对，现在就会感觉比以前完全不一样，
就差别很大。
对，对我来说的话呢，
我自己总结了一下，
其实对我来说是拍摄的内容和一些思路上的变化的过程，
第一个有关于拍摄的内容，
就是我最早的时候就是拍风光，
所以风光对我来说就是，
什么好看我就拍什么，
拍得好不好，跟我没什么关系，
是它好不好看。
靠天吃饭。
对，天气好，后期，
然后你去到川西，去到西藏，去到马带这种地方，
你不可能拍照片，它不好看，
所以你不会很关注你画面是怎么构成的，
但是后来在小红书的早期，
因为草莓做博主嘛，
也算是吃到了早期的这个社交媒体平台的红利，
所以那会儿我们接了非常多的拍摄，
就很多的品牌会寄产品来拍，
然后每次拍的话，其实收入也还不错，
所以非常有动力，
我拍了好几年的类似于这样进物的东西，
从拍风光到拍进物是一个很明显的区别，
就是我知道了画面中应该如何添加元素和减少元素，
就进物摄影和其他摄影方式都不太一样的地方，
就是其他摄影都像是减法，
你在一个世界里面去减掉那些不适合的元素，
然后留下来你要的东西，
但是进物是你先一个空的背景，
你把主体放上去，
你在添加它的一些辅助的东西，
然后一些氛围的东西，
然后灯光一点点的加上去，
所以它更像是在画画的感觉，
然后你就找到了，
原来构图可能是这样子，
物体之间的关系和透视应该是这样子，
就慢慢的慢慢的有了更多的对于画面的理解，
这是一个节点，
另一个节点就是我去马格南读书的那一年，
让我有了项目拍摄的思维，
因为从入学的第一天开始，
他们就说Personal Project,。
你要完成一个project，
然后整一年的时间，
我就围绕着这一个事情，
你在拼命地拍，
然后拼命地去编辑拍，
去拼命地去整理，
去呈现它，
然后去挨骂，
去做得更好，
然后去失望，
然后去觉得开心，
时间这个思维就完全变化了，
所以这是一点，
第二点的话就是对器材的理解，
就虽然我们的节目其实很少聊器材，
但是我以前是一个不折不扣的器材党，
我真的很喜欢买器材，
而且我很喜欢收集东西，
就是我一定要买棋，
大三元，
比如说我刚换到这个尼康的全画符的时候，
我就要买1424，2470，
70200,
然后还有个35，
有个85，有个50，
就说你要有这些镜头，
你就觉得器材好重要啊，
你只有拿到一只好的镜头，
才能拍出好的照片，
所以我当时选的费片里面还有几张，
是那种大光圈照片，
我看到了，
一个钢琴上放了一个小人，
然后这个刀瑞奶画，
是吧,
交对上了，
镜头好，
镜头特别好，
觉得这个镜头太重要了，
设备太重要了，
但是那个阶段的话，
你就不会太关注于你拍了什么，
你关注的只是我的设备好不好，
我的设备是什么样，
所以才会有什么抵达一击压死人，
有这种什么尼康党家能党户，
将这些吵来吵去，
我觉得我现在回头想是能理解的，
到了第二个阶段，
是什么时候呢，
就是在疫情前到疫情之间，
那个时候，
蔡司跟我签了好几年的合约，
就是我做了几年的蔡司签约摄影师，
那会突然之间，
你就有很多很多用不完的镜头，
他们那时候让我用Bartis的系列，
有5只,
然后ZM的系列，
Tweet就是富士的那个卡口，
然后它还有尼康口，家能口，
就你想要什么镜头，
Autos,Mavours什么都有,。
你就随便用，反而就给我用兔了，
拥有的太多，反而就觉得没有意思了，
去妹的最好状态就是拥有了，
就你不再想要新的设备了，
甚至于我一想到我要拍新的设备，
我就很烦，
突然之间觉得设备不重要了，
觉得好像我拿着任何一台设备，
我都可以拍我自己的东西，
这个时候我开始更多的关注画面，
关注内容，关注我到底在拍什么，
然后同时的话因为钱省下来了，
所以我就开始买摄影书，
就以前这些钱你暂念钱，
我就买设备去了，
现在既然这个钱不花了，
那我就把这个钱拿去买摄影书，
那总要花出去是吧，
对总要花出去对吧，
然后收集了一屋子的摄影书，
然后一边看一边去提高，
这是中间的一个阶段，
然后就是到了，
应该说去年初开始吧，
我突然间有了一个新的思路，
就是我觉得器材其实挺重要的，
它的重要不在于你用的什么品牌，
用的什么样子的镜头，
这个镜头好不好，
而在于你使用的这个器材，
是否和你的拍摄内容相关联，
这也是我为什么刚才在选择自己喜欢照片的时候，
我很难从这两张中选择一张，
因为我觉得他们都符合我使用的那个器材，
能够拍出来的比较好的照片的样子，
我从觉得器材很重要，
到它不重要，
到现在回过头去，
我觉得器材其实很重要的，
它和你的表达息息相关，
它和你的工作方式息息相关，
它和你的观察方法息息相关，
所以我觉得从去年到今年，
我自己的提高也蛮多的，
所以这两个变化就是。
我自己整个的摄影的过程中，
一些进步的节点。
我想到我的一个变化，
就是从一个扫射，
就是拿机关枪扫射，
到了我是一个狙击手，
我在等待，
我觉得我的进步是。
在拍摄的方式上的一个变化，
与其说是拍出来的，
不如说是等出来的，
或者找出来的，
所以这个带来的一个点，
就是以前可能拍了很多很多张，
回来可能就一张两张，
就是我们说的这个出片率，
又要说到，
然后现在拍的更少了，
因为要花很多时间去想，
就出片还行，
就我自己觉得我的妈咪啊，
十张里面能出个六七张，
那很高了，很高了，
对，如果说你换到以前，
三十六张都可能出不了几张，
就你拍的更慢了，
然后拍的更细致了，
而且拍十张可能都要花上好久好久时间，
是的，我的方式可能就更大道之间，
就是以前可能很会关注一些，
你怎么构图，
什么光影，什么这些东西，
现在反而是，
你能看到照片你的物体的，
看到照片你的内容，照片你的人，
照片你的场景，
构图或者拍照，
这就是最后的一部分，
就是你前面的过程你能看到了，
反而变得，
你说简单吧，简单，
难也难的，就是，
但是我觉得我其实拍摄数量和。
成片率都没有太大变化，
我以前可能会，
比如说出去玩一天，
我会拍个一千张照片左右，
只是可能更多的是无意识地拍一千张，
我现在还是会拍到一千张左右，
但是呢，
我就会选择一个或者几个，
我觉得好的场景，
我会在这里留的时间会非常长，
比如说我会在一个地方拍一个小时，
两个小时，
就围着这里去拍，
等光线，等人物，等场景，等等等等，
但是我一听回来算下来，
我的数量其实并没有太大的减少，
同时我的初片率也没有太明显的提高，
但是我学会了一件事情，
就是那些不好的照片，
我学会了不发社交媒体，
就你知道哪些值不值得发，
对,
所以其实也有一点，
就是我们刚才讲到，
我们在选择费片的时候，
其实都是从朋友圈里去选的，
所以我们今天看到的照片，
我们自己选出来的照片，
和那个时候选出来的照片，
只是说某种程度上，
我们自己的神媒也提高了，
然后你更多地了解了，
或者你知道了哪些照片是好的，
哪些是不好的，
你就不会把那些不好的照片，
再发到朋友圈里去，
然后给自己制造黑历史，
我觉得这也是一个很重要的点，
是的,
更会选择了，
你知道什么东西好吗？
说到社交媒体，
正好我也想问问你们两位，
就是你们平时是怎么选择照片发社交媒体的，
朋友圈和小红书，
你们会有什么策略吗，
或者会有什么计划吗？
我现在朋友这种状态，
就是如果我拍到一张非常好看的照片，
这张照片我看到很好看，
但是我不会马上发，
我可能会过了好久再发，
为什么？
因为我觉得，
要不去好的东西，
要慢慢分享，
要分享给自己最那个的人，
就是觉得照片很好，
但是不想发的情绪，
我包括我现在其实发朋友圈，
有的时候就也是，
我挑的不是最好看的照片，
只是我觉得可以发，
但是不是最好看的，
也不是我最喜欢的，
如果最喜欢的话，
肯定单独发一张，
或者还要说一下。
那我以前一般一卷胶卷出来了嘛，
就会发几张，
那今年主要发的就是我的一个项目，
因为我找到了自己第一个的拍摄项目，
就是那个上海礼箱。
上海礼箱？
对,对,
然后我就会时不时的发一点发一点，
发了快没了，
手里快没存货了，
也要就提醒我说，
哎呀，又要该去拍了，
该去拍了啊，
对,
这也是个方法，对。
另外再配合一些活人感，
就发点有的没的，
就手机上拍的一些，
就表示啊，
我除了拍照之外，
其实也有在好好生活，对。
对，我也是个人，
对。
上海礼箱这个项目很神奇，
因为这个项目的标题，
它有口音。
嗯，礼箱吗？
上海话，礼箱啊，就礼箱。
对,
就一样的？
一样的，
礼箱,
所以这个名字解的特别好，
这是一个有口音的名字。
对，然后有人还来纠正我，
就说这个箱应该是方向的那个箱，
然后我还给他解释，
我说其实因为这个箱，
更有房间的意思，
所以我就去掉了，
就换成这个，
一间乡房的箱，
叫礼箱。
很好，很好。
我自己的话是这样子，
我比如说我如果去哪里拍摄了，
我平时其实很少拍照，
就是在日常没有项目去拍的时候，
我很少在路上拿着相机随便拍，
或者是日常看到什么东西拍一张，
然后去发一下，
我基本上不会这样子。
所以我一般发照片，
就是我去哪里拍摄了，
或者是去哪里带工作坊，
顺便有时间自己做一些创作。
我在这个过程中的原则，
就是我每天要发一组照片，
就这也是迫使自己，
每天要去拍到足够量的照片，
因为你要选出9张，
还可以的，
说得过去的照片，
那你需要拍的量其实非常大的，
对我来说我可能需要拍到500张以上，
甚至1000张，
我才能从中选出9张这样的照片，
我今天，
我觉得我是满意地制造这照片，
说不上很好，
但是够用了，
我可以发个朋友圈。
那小红书呢，
我通常情况下会智厚一些，
就是等到我回来以后，
我重新选过这些照片，
我选出了比较好的一些，
我才会去整理一下，
然后发一下小红书。
所以朋友圈对我来说，
更像是一个拍摄过程中的，
记录记录我今天拍了什么，
我拍了哪些照片，
我觉得是满意的，
我第二天早上起来，
可能会再看一看，
我觉得好像挺好，
然后有的时候，
也会看看大家的反馈，
有没有人说还不错，
有没有人觉得不好，
或者怎么怎么样，
也给自己一些启发，
然后小红书的话，
更像是一个，
相对来说，
要稍微专业一点点，
就希望营造一个，
比较pro的人设。
学习了，我要学习了，
因为我发的太随意了，
看来就是，
也不是，
讲到这个的话，
其实像刚才白雄
和塞文讲的一样，
包括我们刚才聊到的，
我觉得我们之所以，
觉得自己进步了，
的一个原因，
就是我们知道，
怎么去发社交媒体了，
我们以前其实不知道的，
我们以前是什么都发，
对吧，你今天只要拍了照片，
你不知道的好不好，
我先发个朋友圈再说，
我先发个什么再说，
但也不是，
也没有哎，真的吗，
我会觉得就是，
我以前发的那些照片，
就我选出了一些照片，
你当时是觉得好的是吧，
我当时真的是觉得好的，
我当时真的觉得好，
而且我很喜欢，
我才发出来，
只是说，
现在因为你什么也发生了变化，
你能看到的一张照片，
那东西也更多了，
和以前不一样，
可能以前有一部分是因为，
你拍到照片是因为，
你喜欢这个过程，
你喜欢拍照这个过程，
就喜欢拍交片这个过程，
喜欢拍数码这个过程，
你付出了时间努力，
然后你选的一些照片，
你确实是有这样的心情，
去把这东西分享出来，
其实从那个时候的，
当下去看的话，
它也是喜欢这样照片的，
你是喜欢你才会发出来，
是,是,
那根源上其实还是自己的，
审美和观看提高了，
对，就是人发生了变化，
你说到人设，
我最开始因为，
早几年在那个咖啡的公司做嘛，
我当时还想立个人设是，
每次都喝不一样的咖啡，
想要测评一些咖啡的，
所以早期会有很多，
这种咖啡相关的帖子出来，
然后后来，
又在保佑来研系设，
然后想着哎呀，
我要再立一个，
给大家看看保佑来研系设，
打工的人的这样的一个状态，
然后又开始发一点什么，
我在研系设上班，
类似这种话题的题，
我还记得，
然后现在就是，
我觉得小红书，
不是一个很严肃看照片的地方，
然后呢，
我自己也没有个人网站，
但你们两位都有，
是,
然后虽然，
也催着我要有个个人网站，
我觉得有一个个人网站，
才是一个比较严肃的，
系统的去回顾自己作品的一个地方，
小红书其实，
稍微还是有一点随意的，
对,
所以发小红书，
封面要不要选个，
就看起来有意思点，
更有网感的，
对,
就有的时候就很烦恼，
这是我阻碍我发小红书最大的动力，
就是你在这个平台，
你还是得迎合这个平台的，
怎么说一些调性吧，
你完全如果不迎合，
然后你又要在那边抱怨说，
我没流量，
什么摄影，
没有人看，
也好像不合适，
那既然你在这个平台，
你就稍微利用一点这个平台的，
这种生存方式吧，
游戏规则，
对,
但是我会觉得有一个问题啊，
就是小红书，
如果我们去迎合他所带来的这些，
像白熊说的游戏规则，
或者说，
他所带来的某种审美风格，
有没有可能，
几年之后我们再回看，
如果我们按照这种方式来创作，
我们来做的东西，
会不会就是我们今天看过去的，
废片一样的感受，
因为流行这个东西，
其实我觉得挺可怕的，
我们之前讲到的那些什么，
黑白加上单色，
阿宝色，
赛伯朋克，
然后包括赛文说到的，
在照片上加上这个，
日文韩文的水印，对吧，
这都是曾经的流行，
那今天小红书，
也会不断的去给大家推流行的内容，
流行的拍摄的点，
拍摄的机位，
拍摄的场景，
视觉风格，
我有的时候，
经常会刷到，
很多的博主，
有同样的拍的东西，
特别多，
同样的风格，
同样使用闪光灯，
同样拍某种元素，
同志化特别严重，
那会看看觉得也挺好的，
但是你过两年，
再回头去看这些照片的时候，
它会不会就是我们以前的这些，
废片了？
我觉得是这样的，
就是对于当下的我来讲，
如果说我创作，
我肯定是，
按照我自己想拍什么，
想做什么样的创作去做，
但是就像白熊说的，
你如果是，
你做完创作之后，
你确实要去，
希望更多的人看到你的作品，
看到你的东西，
那么你在做营销，
或者是做你在宣传这些图的时候，
去适当的，
去迎合它的一些方式，
比如说，
去一个好看的标题，
或者是稍微的，
就是抽象一点的东西，
去弄一下，
我觉得这个没有问题，
这种是，
基于说，
我自己的东西我是不变的，
我核心是不变的，
我只是说，
在形式上，
或者在宣传模式上，
我去迎合一下你，
我觉得这个我能接受的。
我同意赛文，
就是拍什么东西，
还是自己决定，
就是那个封面图和文字，
或者说，
比如说拍胶片，拍保利来，
可能出了一个新的胶卷，
我去拍一下，
出了一个新相织，
它也会有一些，
新产品的这种热度在里面，
但拍什么，
还是我自己决定。
那你们会因为，
流量不好，
焦虑吗？
就比如说，
你拍的东西，
是你自己喜欢的，
但是,
你发出去之后，
没有那么多人看，
也没有那么多的战场，
没有那么多的反馈，
你们会焦虑，
然后去说，
哎呀,
我要不拍一些，
更有流量的东西，
会吗?
我觉得有这样的时刻。
我之前有一个想法，
就是这张照片，
谁发,
其实很重要，
就这张照片，
可能我发，
或者老潘发，
或者赛文发，
或者说，
Mark Power,。
他发了一张我的照片，
可能真的都比我自己，
本人发，
流量要高，
没错,
对，那这就无所谓了呀，
是的,
因为有些人，
他至少在这个平台，
或者在社交媒体上，
他已经掌握了，
说有一定的优势，
所以这个优势，
是你没办法说，
你一下通过很好的作品，
就能去抹平的，
他就是，
有的人，
我就认认，
我觉得这个人拍的就是好的，
对,
就是有的人就会觉得，
大师拍的都是好的，
就点赞疯狂的，
这流量也很好，
这很正常，
嗯,
想通这个点，
我就不焦虑了，
我只要做我自己，
认为正确的事情，
万一我去迎合了，
比如说我也去拍什么，
就是不是我喜欢的东西，
对,
可能获得一时的快乐，
但是,
长久来还是没有什么，
成就感的，
我就说获得一时快乐，
其实也可以，
就是如果你在其中，
能获得快乐，
我觉得也是可以，
实在不行，
你就打钱嘛，
对吧，你就投嘛，
那个薯条，
还不如去麦当劳，
买包薯条来的效果好，
说实话，
对啊,
你,
如果能这么想的话，
其实也能想通嘛，
对,
刚才白雄说的这个例子，
就是关于，
谁来发这张照片的重要性，
我想讲一个很有趣的，
小故事，
是Mark在上海做工作坊期间，
他拍了一张照片，
他的照片呢，
是有的时候是，
他是2%的机身家，
Face后背,
他会用两张竖图，
或者两张横图，
进行拼接，
他那张图呢，
是两张竖图的拼接，
一个路口，
对面是一个，
上海的老的建筑，
可能正在改造，
类似于在，
要改造的这个样子，
然后一个十字路口，
他两张竖图拼接之后，
在图上，
其实出现了两个，
同样的人，
他是一个失误，
他没有发现了，
其实,
他拍第一张照片的时候，
这个人是骑着电瓶车，
背着往前走的，
结果正常情况下，
他不就开走了吗？
结果好巧不巧呢，
这个大姐，
他到红绿灯口，
他可能觉得自己走错路了，
他掉头回来了，
所以在他拍第二张照片的时候，
又拍到了这位朋友的正面，
他后面把两张照片拼接在一起的时候，
就出现了一张照片里面，
同时拥有了左右两个，
一样的人，
一个正面，
一个背面的，
这样子的一个照片，
你就可以看到下面的留言，
说,
哇，这是个好神奇的时刻，
说他们俩是这个，
双胞胎嘛，
然后,
怎么拍到这样的照片，
怎么做到的呢，
就是没有人质疑，
说这是不是个失误，
对,
因为我跟妈妈看完这个评论之后，
我们俩就，
哈哈大笑，
说这个，
其实就是失误，
爸可以说好丢脸，
但是,
他又觉得很好玩，
对,
所以确实是，
就很难，
有的时候，
比如说你拿一些，
像沃尔夫刚的照片，
或者是谁的照片，
你拿去给完全不了解声音的人去看，
或者是，
一些朋友去看，
他们其实，
你没有办法说这个东西好不好的，
嗯,
他说你这拍的是什么东西，
对,
像那个，
保罗格雷勒姆拍的那个，
巴黎的，
孔西之后的那个，
房间里的照片，
对吧,
这如果是我拍的，
肯定得骂我，
这什么破玩意儿，
所以,
艺术是，
艺术家创造的，
这个从现成品开始，
就是这样子，
所以没办法，
那为什么我会想这个话题呢，
其实是因为我的一个摄影师朋友，
我不说他剧拍的是什么了，
说的话，
可能都能猜到是谁，
就他之前拍了某一个主题，
在小红书上流量非常非常好，
然后他也获得了不少的粉丝，
不少的订阅，
还有一些关注，
那,
他其实现在不想拍这个了，
他想拍别的东西，
他做了一些尝试，
他就发现他只要不拍这个主题，
他拍B主题之后，
拍另外一个主题之后，
流量就明显下降，
所以他非常焦虑，
他跟我聊了好几次这个话题，
我发现他最近又回去拍A主题了，
至少他在小红书上发的东西，
都是他之前的那个主题，
某种程度上说他是没办法，
但是确实是流量对于摄影的影像，
就像被流量裹写了，
发小红书有的时候确实是会这样，
因为你认真的去编辑了你的作品，
照片也是认真拍的，
你当然希望能够发出去之后，
有很多的关注，
有很多的点赞，
所以如果说他没有达到女预期，
或者说你很喜欢东西，
结果只有几个赞，
你会有天然的失落，
就会有这种焦虑，
如果他本身是说，
我本身就是有很有粉丝，
或者说我要依靠小红书这个平台，
去做一些说话，
去谋生也好，
或者连线也好，
那么他肯定会有角律，
因为就夹在这生存角律，
对,对,
所以其实挺不容易的，
今天对摄影师来说，
想要有一个展示自己作品的好的空间，
几乎可以说是没有，
你要想好的曝光，
只没首先没有，
然后个人网站，
国内几乎没有去阅读别人个人网站的习惯，
就哪怕我们有个人网站，
其实也并不是为了让别人去看，
或者是能够收获一些流量，
他更多的是对自己作品的一个整理，
以及在有必要的时候，
能够提供给别人的东西，
比如说之前我给安娜Fox介绍佳麟的时候，
安娜就问说他有没有个人网站，
我想去他的个人网站上看他更多的东西，
所以其实对白熊也好，
或者是对佳麟也好，
我们也是建议两位，
抓紧时间，
能够把自己的个人网站做起来，
又被催了，又被催了，
还是挺重要的，
可以的用AI做嘛，AI还挺好的，
而且现在有很多现成的模板，
其实可以用，
这很方便的，而且设计也很好，
没错,
虽然它不是一个或许流量的东西，
但它至少是一个你就完全展示。
个人作品的一个平台吧，
就确实，
我们今天讲的这些话题，
回过头来看摄影师也太不容易了，
在国内你想找到一个。
真正的好的展示自己的平台，
太难太难太难了，
所以也能够理解吧，
潘老师靠你了，
把价格打下来，
做不了做不了做不了，
肯定会死，
做不了，
所以从商业的角度考虑，
也确实没有机构，
或者是个人能够做这种东西，
就很难，
所以只能大家自己各自努力啦，
那今天节目到这里的话呢，
我觉得我们聊的差不多了，
从费片开始，
我们回顾自己过去的那些照片，
再看自己的进步，
从何而来，
再讨论一下，
在社交媒体时代，
我们会不会被设没影响，
那这就是我们今天的主要内容，
看看两位还有什么要补充的没有，
没事，就不要害怕拍费片吧，
那些都是你走过的路，
你只有一张一张的费片拍出来之后，
才慢慢的拍到你自己喜欢的照片，
嗯,
怎么都还要上价值最后，
这价值嘛，
这确实也是这样一个道理，
就是我回看自己的，
就以前拍的东西，
就是这样一个感觉，
虽然你现在看，
你会觉得不知道拍了什么，
但是正是因为你当时，
你拍的那些照片，
你依然非常的喜欢，
能够发到社交媒体上，
有这样的动力去做，
不停的拍，不停的拍，
你才慢慢的拍出了你现在的照片。
费的心安理德，
拍的理直气壮，
这个是我的美好祝愿，
送给大家，
而且这个费片，
听上去像个贬义词，
但其实都是你的，
进步的电脚诗，
然后还要宣传一下，
就是photo-reason,。
这个小红书账号，
我们本月发起了一个，
就是费片在哪里，
它的灵感也是，
拍的最差的摄影师，
那个真的很有意思。
也希望大家可以，
勇敢的去展示一下，
自己以前拍的不好的，
说说为什么不好，
可以给大家有一些启发，
然后这一期的投稿，
也是申请了有贞送离品，
是我们的photo-reason的，
苏干华夫格短袖，
以及有风苏干的短裤一套，
对的，那最后在结束之前，
我也上一个小价值，
这段话呢，
其实来自于，
他所付，
是我之前给他做采访的时候，
就当时我问他说，
我说我拍一百张照片，
可能只有几张是好的，
我说你会不会焦虑，
或者会怎么样，
他说,
啊，你成功率这么高啊，
他说你好照片的比例这么高啊，
他说我拍一千张照片，
只有一张好照片，
甚至没有，
所以大家也不用焦虑，
说我一天拍下来，
可能没有拍到好照片，
甚至我一趟旅行，
拍下来没有好照片，
而且在这次，
在这次伊斯坦波尔工作坊结束之前，
艾米也跟我说，
他说,
我觉得你应该，
这次非常开心，
首先工作坊效果很好，
然后接着你拍到了一张，
很好的照片，
那他觉得，
我如果在一次旅行中，
在一次拍摄中，
又有这样的一张照片，
你就够了，
你就应该足够为自己骄傲了，
我觉得这个也很好，
所以大家不要焦虑，
不要担心说，
我的照片怎么还没有来，
我的好照片怎么还没有来，
它可能只是时间和量的积累，
就是量变最终，
还是会引起制变的，
大家尽可能多拍，
然后加油，
加油,
好，那今天节目就到这里，
感谢大家收听，
欢迎大家加入Photoreason的社群，
和我们一起来聊摄影，
我们下期节目再见，
说声拜拜，
拜拜,
朋友们再见，